just south of los angeles is the
picturesque beach town of manhattan
beach
five years ago lisa hemet an ambitious
23 year old fresh at a usc business
school bought a restaurant called lido d
manhattan hey guys how are you welcome
to lena
i think i do surprise a lot of people
based on first impression and
seeing someone as young as i am and
female i think they are surprised thanks
for joining us most people still think
that my parents gave it to me or i
married somebody that gave it to me it
was just frustrating but at the same
time i know the truth
i went to usc and studied business
entrepreneurship
so after i graduated college i was bound
and determined to only work for myself
but instead of starting from scratch i
started looking at existing businesses
with staff with customer base and lido
just seemed like a real great fit
i don't think it looks good like what
one big table lisa did not at that time
have the experience to run
a full restaurant in my opinion i think
we should separate them the only thing
at that point in time that i believe
really helped this restaurant be a
success was that she did have a staff
that had been here
forever
safe list is very
smart person but she doesn't have a lot
of experience with the restaurant i
don't want to hear complaints i don't
want to hear [ __ ] i just want to hang
out
if you see a wine key i took it from
priscilla
a lot of times she gets things mixed up
like she considers me as a friend not as
an employee
do you have this phone number
why are there morocco
they've been there you put them there on
your i didn't i can't reach that damian
is a bar manager
and someone that i have been kind of
dating in the last six months
thank you
i don't think that i have a title if she
sees something that needs to be done and
will ask me to do it i'll do it are you
okay
no give me these just relax
i kind of cross this fuzzy line where
i'm having him work here it's probably a
bad idea but
i'm gonna do it anyways
[Music]
it's heartbreaking to me to see other
people choosing other restaurants around
here
i struggle with
why it's not busier than it is
if a little doesn't change
things here i don't think we'll be open
until
the beginning of the next year
i've just been so frustrated i'm barely
making it by
and
i can't continue on like this
[Music]
parking lot is jammed so my big question
is what's the problem with the
restaurant i'm about to find out
hello hi how are you hi welcome how are
you good i'm lisa henning lisa nice to
see you you're the owner you're the
owner yeah um so just very quickly
you've owned business for how long i've
been here for five years you don't look
that old
hold on if you don't know where else 28.
28. so you got it when you were 23. yeah
how did you manage to get richer 23. i
was just determined when i graduated
college and you graduated from where usc
marshall school business yeah what was
that a graduation present no dad didn't
buy me a restaurant dad co-signed on a
loan for me
um so i'm gonna have a quick bite to eat
okay thank you
go ahead and have you guys there cause
all these colors who come up with these
colors the previous owners came up with
the colors i kind of have kept it the
way it was right what's changed since
you took over from the older russians i
haven't changed too much
um what in five years yeah and five
years so this is the same menu that was
off the previous owners a la carte
right the hedges name is luis martinez
and luis has been here for 18 years and
the sous chef is his brother arturo okay
good
what would you recommend this filet
wrapped in pancetta topped with a
homemade balsamic reduction sauce but
i'm actually vegetarian
just just say that again sorry
yes i'm vegetarian you're vegetarian
yeah right so char gold filet but hold
the fillet yeah that dish is awesome
thank you
well
say
bizarre
hello how are you priscilla priscilla
nice to meet you you're a server okay
makes sense thank you
priscilla i think i'm ready uh seeing as
the owner is vegetarian
the baked eggplant roll and then the
spicy rahi tower please
and then the tortellini pasta salad okay
yeah thank you you're welcome
young man how are you
damien uh i'm uh the bar manager and the
catering director there's a big title
catering director and bar manager all at
once well done is lisa a good boss lisa
is a lovely boss yes
lovely boss sometimes when they refer to
the boss as being lovely it sounds like
it's an intimate lovely
oh
she's not wrong with it no is that no i
am dating lisa yes
okay dad right that's why she's lovely
got you now okay
[Music]
thank you um and these are stuffed with
mozzarella cheese mozzarella thank you
oh dear and it doesn't have very
appetizing
[Music]
[Music]
crunchy eggplant undercooked
the eggplant's raw that's why it's gone
so black take the back because it's like
pulled in grease but no problem eggplant
shouldn't be crunchy
oh dear
oh yeah yeah you send it back because
the eggplant is not cooked properly
this is the high tower appetizer thank
you
ah dear i feel like there's a firework
display taking place on my plate
rocket man
something is wrong i can't tell his face
i'm so compressed it feels like he's
been done two days ago
much spicy eye tuna
[Music]
that tuna doesn't taste fresh it's
grainy and it's furry yeah
you've been sat there watching me
come on
hey come on
nana come on i thought he was gonna like
some of our food i know
that's just gross
oh did you like no i didn't is it is it
frozen tuna no it's fresh tonight is it
yeah i'll buy pasta go to the next one
thank you though
funny how owner's not even in the
kitchen you said one must take two
mistakes she's just standing there
hanging out and chilling out it's
driving me crazy
he said that he tastes like frozen tuna
it is frozen tuna
i told him it was fresh
here's the bad news so far not a slim
ray of sunshine not even a glimmer of
hope anywhere on the food
chicken tortellini pasta salad excellent
good now is that home cooked those are
not homemade
thanks
[Music]
what is that in there
it tastes like rubber
that
is hideous
yeah not very pleasant
no i mean there's just stone cold i'm
sorry ask lisa to taste the toad lean
just the vegetarian part all right i'll
see
i still think it tastes good
everything vegetarian at least i've
tried i love so i think our food
tastes great to me it really does
vegetarian owner lisa has relied on the
martinez brothers hi guys hello come
around and a menu she inherited from the
previous owner
and chef ramsay was not impressed
so
what hurts more than anything was how
bad the food was
i can't think of a worse vegetable to
serve raw and a slice a crunchy eggplant
why is your restaurant that's on his ass
cooking frozen pasta with a ship filling
and frozen tuna to the biggest insults
well i have to cook it so are you
powerless to talk we talk but we don't
have the power here to make decisions we
don't get the last word
jesus christ
lisa come on who runs this restaurant
who's in charge
i'm in charge so you're giving them the
permission to cook like this
yeah i guess
[ __ ] me
i've had a [ __ ] luncheon i'm embarrassed
and you tell me you run the place yeah
but you don't have the initiative to
identify
that [ __ ]
why
i didn't know you didn't know no you
don't need a degree to [ __ ] identify
that crap trust me i think he's being a
little over dramatic we do overall have
customers that do enjoy the food and you
tell me you run the place
i guess i didn't think of it as that
horrible or bad you're dreaming
sweetheart
[Music]
after an uninspiring lunch chef ramsay
is looking for some good news in
tonight's dinner service
enjoy your dinner welcome my name is
damian and i'll be taking care of you
tonight i'm gonna go with the uh
[Music]
um the computers have been an issue for
me from day one uh it's really outdated
the keyboard's not even working properly
so you keep pressing pressing pressing
doesn't work
it's
[Music]
ridiculous god how old is this thing
it's uh i think about
30 years old everything is coded like
numbers for each and every order that's
correct sometimes all the buttons don't
work jesus christ
you have a ticket for
108.
they don't have a ticket for 108. please
double check if you have my tickets 104
and 105.
uh no
it's absolutely madness this whole
computerized system is a [ __ ]
nightmare
i hate the computer whenever we kind of
busy like really put us behind the
computer just sucks
while an antiquated ordering system
creates havoc for the front of the house
and the kitchen chef luis pushes on and
manages to get entrees out to the dining
room
completely off i think it's really gummy
it's frozen
why would somebody want to make this
very gummy
she's right yummy she's being polite i
think that lisa doesn't know at all
what's going on with the kitchen
what's this here louie
when was all this done
so we're searing tuna on a monday for
thursday yeah
what are you doing look at the color of
it
get me lisa please
i'm getting really nervous now this is
seared on monday
for thursday
we can't see a tuna to order
that's why it doesn't taste good does
that make business upstairs
when was the last time you looked in
this fridge uh i never really examined
it
no
oh dear
lisa how long ago do you think that was
sliced
i don't know roughly a couple days a
couple of days it's like pastrami
but that is scary
oh yeah yeah like i don't know these
things are going on unless someone tells
me and they haven't told me dinner
service is off to a rough start
customers are unhappy
the food is far from fresh and lisa the
owner is unaware of many of the problems
in her own kitchen
but as bad as it is it's about to get
worse
oh my god
that's disgusting
when was last time this place was
[Music]
stop
you stop
everybody stop
[Music]
lisa come here two seconds come here
when was the last time this place was
cleaned they should be cleaning every
day but look
just here
just everywhere disgusting look at it
this is above food
i mean come on luis i am not serving
food like this okay
that is disgusting
i don't think it really has affected or
gone in the food like how do you know
we have customers to serve right now and
people okay do me a favor right now you
serve those customers right now i'm out
of here your [ __ ] choice because you
think i'm going to stand there
what do i want
[ __ ] it i'll do it this way then
excuse
me excuse me
all these tables here can i borrow for
two seconds please follow me
sir come through madam come true i just
stopped serving food in here because of
the [ __ ] and the dust
are you interested in being served
dinner with that filth
dripping in your food
does anyone who eat now
[Music]
that's your customers you need me to
tell you that
laugh i'm not laughing i think you're a
jerk you should be embarrassed
excuse me
it's a little bit gross like that but
was it really affecting our food tonight
no like did he need to make a huge
spectacle
and embarrass me in front of all my
customers no
lisa
i'm over it
lisa what do you mean you come out make
us look like [ __ ] in front of like
friends and customers
lisa first thing i said can we stop
serving food you're totally oblivious to
what's happening in your business you
may have bought the rest of the 23 might
darling but you're not [ __ ] running
it grow up lisa will you
[Music]
it's an hour into dinner service chef
ramsay has uncovered an unsanitary
situation in the kitchen grow up lisa
will you and lisa has escaped the
bathroom
as for the kitchen they're about to get
some much-needed direction not from the
owner
but from gordon don't stand clean
everybody grab a towel and start
cleaning
the kitchen it's disgusting i mean we're
talking about inches of dirt it's gross
i mean look at this he's right it's
[ __ ] filthy
dinner service is full force right now
we've got 93 people in the restaurant
that need their food and dinner service
is stopped i don't know what else to do
where is lisa has she gone upstairs
restaurant yet she's in the restaurant
you know
she's in the restroom and the
restaurant's in the [ __ ] insulting
precious princess
lisa
i can't go out there i need to face and
fix it yeah
i have never seen lisa like that or
upset like that ever she's a very tough
person lisa you're really strong of
course you can handle it
i didn't expect she was going to react
to like this damn it okay that's fine
yeah that's clean man yeah it's the
cleanest i've ever seen it
larry okay we start firing up again now
yeah
yeah
there's least around the toilet yet
not yet she's still there she's still in
there that's nearly an hour
[Music]
i've been here for an hour and twenty
minutes i'm not dying
we've been waiting too long
is she okay did she go to the bathroom
do you want to go check on her or i can
choose would you mind
[Music]
she's not gonna come out for nothing we
are trying really hard because you're
giving up
no
come on
a dismal dinner service comes to an end
not even an appetite
with disappointed customers leaving
unsatisfied as for lisa she finishes off
the service still sequestered in the
bathroom
[Music]
i didn't really expect it to be this
hard i try my best and
i really want the best for this
restaurant
yes
i don't know
i feel pretty helpless right
so that was a [ __ ] night
mm-hmm
you got upset
and you disappeared yeah
that's not the way to face problems what
was i supposed to do
like do you want me to go back and dust
like i don't get what you're trying to
say okay right now so is that the kind
of trick that they teach you in an
honors degree
to disappear in a toilet like a precious
princess
i don't think of myself as like a
princess i really don't like just think
i am an average person working hard for
all my dreams you bought the restaurant
yeah that was the easy part purchasing
the hardest part was the following day
running the [ __ ] thing he said i you
know no one's ever told you the truth
but more importantly i think you're in
denial
why am i here
because we need help and i'm missing a
key ingredient obviously because we have
a good location i have a great staff i
have a good energy i
i love the place
something's missing okay i'm gonna give
you a business assignment tonight back
to the good old days usc i need five
real clear
changes that you want to make tomorrow
to be implemented
okay
tomorrow
new start
those five issues may start to really
help convince me why you did this five
years ago
okay
good night good night thank you
[Music]
last night lisa failed her test as a
restaurant owner but today chef ramsay
is hoping she will do a better job with
her homework assignment
[Music]
um right where's lisa right here good
morning
i trust you to be in the bathroom when i
came in this morning
so last night we had a little chat and i
asked lisa to come up with five
instrumental changes that she wants to
put into this place to make a
significant difference i want to hear
what those are i'll give you one thank
you
[Music]
okay five things that i would like to
change about lido today
be proud of the food we're serving keep
a clean and sanitary environment
everywhere
the customers should be impressed by the
ambiance and decor not disgusted
we need to tighten up the menu and stay
with one theme that works
okay fifth it's more for me to learn how
the kitchen operates yeah good job a
plus
you've clearly shown me that you know
the problems the hardest thing now is
following it through yes last night was
rock bottom but i think you know i'm
gonna have to embrace these changes and
make sure they happen
there's one
issue that i'm concerned about that you
haven't managed to tackle
in fact let me show you
it'll be easier doing this way
[Music]
pos
piece of [ __ ] that
is the biggest headache inside this
restaurant they press less buttons
at nasa launching astronauts in space i
swear to god
yes yes
[Music]
when he started to just break the
computer i couldn't believe it i was
in shock
that was my dream come true let's go
lisa let the frustrations go
[Music]
priscilla's next
i won't dream anymore go go go go
this is for all the hard time i had with
this piece of [ __ ] i hate it
come on big boy let's go
don't hurt yourself i hate this thing
okay
[Music]
done with you oh that felt good
while professor ramsey is impressed with
lisa's homework and her intentions for
the restaurant class now continues in
the kitchen where gordon is ready to
educate lisa and her chefs so two
changes tonight yes okay very simple
we'll do a linguine of crab and we'll do
a tuna salad nicoise
okay sounds good okay so first thing
we're gonna seal the tuna nice and
gently done yeah
is it always cooked at the same
temperature yeah the better the quality
the least it needs cooking okay i don't
know much about food so i thought it was
extremely exciting and what an
opportunity to watch someone like gordon
ramsay to go with the tuna nicoise we've
got a couple of potatoes on there it
just looks so fresh and flavorful
vibrant okay gorgeous done beautiful
right linguine yeah
white wine in
[Music]
dungeness crabbing
fresh lime juice right at the very end
yeah it's beautiful absolutely
[Music]
after a rough first day lisa now has a
positive attitude and chef ramsay is
hoping right let's have a quick briefing
she is ready for another assignment lisa
the boss you're going to do something
you haven't done in five years
tonight
you yeah here we are
we're on the line
that's right
yeah
show me a joke uh i'm very serious
i'm a little nervous about hurting
myself i hate knives i cut myself when i
was like three years old so i never
would have expected to put me on the
line like that i'll see you in a minute
we're opening five minutes
hello hi hi right this way your menu
just so you ladies know in addition to
our menu we have two specials chef
ramsay has put lisa in charge of
tonight's specials that's for you apron
perfect he wants her to begin to
understand the inner workings of her
kitchen
something she has avoided in the past it
definitely came as a shock to me i'm
thinking about the sear doggie and i'm
going to have the crabs
all right thank you very much folks
you're welcome
okay there we go first order ah tuna
yeah i didn't understand what we were
doing i was i was really confused why is
this not turning on lisa get comfortable
with it yeah get comfortable where is
this line turning on
this is hot i don't know what to do with
it keep it here at least it was like
touching little things like doing this
oh ouch oh it's odd wow it's hot
lisa you gotta
move fast
whoa
why is that flaming
[Music]
that's getting the microwave yeah why
isn't it going in there
i think it's a very valid point why is
it going in the microwave why can't it
go the oven's on yeah yeah it's on can
you see what i'm trying to say
it's really important for you to see
this
to see a dish go directly to the
microwave i was just i was really
shocked we're not here spending all this
money on microwave food why would we do
that we're so [ __ ] used to
microwaving [ __ ] how do we flavor out of
a [ __ ] microwave so good for you to
see this i cannot tell you
it's an hour into dinner service and
while chef ramsay's specials prepared
capably by lisa are a hit did you like
it that was really good the old menu
cooked by the kitchen staff is a flop
this is not worth 24
tonight was crazy i probably had like
seven items send it back i ordered a
medium rare which is
terrible like that's not working no
problem i'll take this back
no problem
in general the plates going back to the
kitchen was frustrating for me medium
rare please that's rare it seemed like
something went wrong with every one of
my tables
it's overcooked i am very frustrated
what's going on uh it's overcooked what
is that this lamb is overcooked please
read fire
what temperature you want medium hey you
did right the temperature that's why
well this is overcooked no no no we
fired it right
now i realize that arturo and louise
like to shift blame all the time like no
one can take responsibility really write
down the ticket okay so medium please
okay we got it we got it let's go okay
we got it can we just re-fire it first
and we'll argue after service please
everyone is yelling and being angry it
just tears it apart like you can't do
that we fire that medium
it's overcooked take that back for you
aside from the successful dinner
specials tonight's dinner service has
been a disaster re-fire that medium
thank you yes thank you and chef ramsay
is looking for someone to take control
[Music]
okay we're gonna make it right now sorry
guys thank you
how's that pork coming six minutes six
minutes two ahi towers and one calamari
right lisa you're in control now yeah
yeah good let's go passes in the window
there it is yes got it
i feel like once i kind of learned my
dishes it i was like come on what's next
what's next let's get it together 127.
yes so
amazing
what's going on now it's vital to know
what's going on in the kitchen as a
owner operator i should have done it
years ago thank you for coming out and
hopefully we see you again soon
okay tonight you're good thank you but
here's the bad news
i can't think
of a worse scenario than having lazy
chefs it is the quickest way of closing
down a business i'm willing
to work with arturo and luis but just
everything has to change
[Music]
lisa's ability to change has inspired
chef ramsay to implement a change of his
own a drastic remodel of lido that he
and his team work through the night to
complete
[Music]
good morning good morning today big day
nido is relaunching ready yes do it yes
yes time to see the new lido let's go
come here come here come in
[Music]
come in come in come in come in come
over oh my god
it's beautiful first thing
that horrendous wall that was dividing
your restaurant has gone now the whole
thing just feels open easier to get
round
wow
oh that's so cool new seating brand new
bonkets check out the new china
no more hideous colors all the plates
and all the little small bits of china
were from webstorm straw i was totally
speechless i love what they did with the
curtains with the lighting with the
pictures one thing this area hasn't got
and one thing you've got every chance of
succeeding in is becoming my hands yeah
local
cool
wine bar
serving great food great wines by the
glasses more importantly a very cool
place to hang out i think a wine bar is
exactly what manhattan beach needed
there's no place out there
around here that has that one more
little surprise you've got to see these
persistent before was useless this is
phenomenal
[Music]
i was so surprised when i saw the new
system no way i couldn't believe it i
was
in shock this is designed by halo it's
the most advanced restaurant pos system
anywhere in the world
wow i believe in you i believe in the
staff you've got to pull this off we
will oh definitely we have to
not only will the new decor be on
display tonight chef ramsay has
overhauled the food and designed an
exciting wine friendly menu for what he
is hoping will be the new hot spot in
manhattan beach
wow
it's a lot of food that's so pretty
let's start off on the top the homemade
chicken sausage grilled baby artichokes
and delight one of my favorites
flatbreads they are fantastic you've got
a chance to gain a serious reputation
mm-hmm right on trace i'll leave you a
burger grilled mint steak i think it's
gonna be a huge hit here i love the new
menu it's so tasty it's easy and i think
it's perfect
[Music]
despite a poor performance last evening
lisa is hoping her kitchen staff are
motivated by the changes and that they
will rise to the occasion for the most
important night in lido's history one
two three leaders
do it
[Music]
welcome to the new lido
enjoy some wine tonight yeah that's
great
this is our new menu we have some new
appetizers also
okay how would you like that to be
cooked you know that rare please yeah oh
i'm nervous
i'm so happy with this computer
here we go guys yes yes concentrate guys
yeah
20 minutes
louie i need some stuff coming out here
guys huh
there's tickets was piled in the kitchen
oh geez
in spite of a new ordering system 30
minutes into service no entrees have
left the kitchen and there appears to be
a communication breakdown
here no one's even working together it
starts off from the chef calling out the
order so away now one skeleton
fettuccine 1101 grilled steak nobody
answers me
yes yeah yes yeah i'm begging just to
talk to each other i'm begging
about the [ __ ] menu being put up
together collectively at the same time
yeah that's what's not happening
i was a little nervous right then
because with my relaunch i really wanted
to run smooth unfortunately there's no
communication it's awful
[Music]
unbelievable dining room looks
absolutely beautiful fine great granted
but the kitchen an absolute [ __ ]
disaster five headless chickens with not
an ounce of leadership qualities right
now i'm depending on a 20 year old lady
to save her restaurant the biggest test
i've been career so far
60 minutes into service the kitchen
staff is finally communicating and
sending out entrees however they are not
being well received by the dining room
[Music]
i need 115 and 60. all of these steaks
are called oh come on
they're
guys
as well
listen to me when a minute steak is
cooked it's got to be served straight
away you can't hold a minute steak three
steaks on the fly as quick as you can
when people are getting their food
they're getting undercooked overcooked
still sending it back they want a whole
new steak [ __ ] you know there's more
food going in the [ __ ] trash that is
going on on the [ __ ] table we either
need our food like five minutes or our
check
90 minutes into relaunch diners are fed
up with not being fed if you don't want
and lisa is desperate for her kitchen to
bounce back
oh my gosh look at that
[Music]
those are the tickets
[Music]
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing are you kidding me right now this
is ridiculous like i just couldn't
believe the the ignorance back there
what are you doing
why aren't you making food why are you
standing here
you're just looking at tickets make some
[ __ ] food i don't understand please
arturo will you please tell her to make
some food i think i'm trying right now
i'm scheduling my stuff too oh this is
stupid
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god hello we're giving up
we're giving up yeah i know you give
[Music]
on my biggest night
they walked out
please guys
[Music]
they're leaving who's leaving we're
giving that we're giving up bye
oh my god
it's relaunch night at leados and the
only thing that's taken off is the
kitchen staff
larry
please guys for them to walk out like
that with all those tickets like i
wasn't sure what to do or what to expect
the head chef after 18 years bails out
that's [ __ ] spineless
[Music]
hello
scottish gordon uh listen i need you
right now
jump in the car and get down here
quickly will you please
[Music]
lisa i've just phoned scott i told him
to jump in his car and he's getting down
here chef scott's been my right-hand man
for the last five years okay i've asked
him to be here as your consultant for
the next month to oversee this [ __ ]
place he's gonna jump on the service and
get this place up to speed we cannot
afford to let this place go down no
chance
with an empty kitchen and a full dining
room relaunch night at lido is heading
towards disaster i don't even know what
to do even though chef scott is on his
way they're all running away like
cowards gordon makes one more attempt to
get the disgruntled kitchen staff back
yeah we need you larry
this is my ears
[Music]
thank you
okay scott yeah
look scott's here yeah look he's here to
help let's lift it up and let's let's
let's get this back together yes okay
okay here we go listen up everybody i
need a prosciutto pizza in the oven i
need one margarita barbecued chicken i
need a lamb sandwich up top right now
to see scott in the kitchen like take
command the way he did that shows what a
head chef should be doing is that
prosciutto pizza in the oven yeah okay
if i'm not three minutes four minutes
three minutes i saw a communication i'd
never seen in that kitchen before with
scott at the rings it's okay let's pick
up carpala rosemary chicken steak medium
rare going with the prosciutto pizza
table 106. thank you
jeff scott helped the kitchen make a
massive comeback i have a clam 2 tartare
and asparagus quiche and the evening
ended successfully wow
i think tonight overall was a good
learning experience
thank you very much okay and near my
last table serve tonight so i'm looking
forward to talking with gordon about
what i should do and moving forward with
this restaurant because we really really
need a solid kitchen staff
okay lisa honestly you have seriously
grown up this week more than i ever
expected to do you show
such commitments you do your homework
you show up on time and more importantly
you are a very fast learner however it's
not the same with the team your kitchen
staff in a normal situation would have
been expelled then walking out like that
in the middle of service was disgusting
i 100 agree that was horrible your dream
effectively is in their hands i'm so
disappointed tonight i can't put up with
that [ __ ] i'm not sure whether luis and
arturo are gonna be part of the new leto
but now that i have a much better
understanding from gordon i am going to
really embrace these changes and make
this place successful i am so impressed
with the way you've handled what you've
had to do
in this short period of time you stay in
control and you hold the reins firmly i
seriously believe in you thank you
i can't wait to come back i can't wait
to have you back i'll be your honor
student when gordon walks back in here
whenever he comes back in months from
now and sees this restaurant buzzing
that's going to be my proudest moment
good night what am i doing thank you so
much good luck spend time with that
kitchen
okay good thank you
[Music]
tonight was actually the first night
this place felt like lisa's restaurant
sadly there are still leftovers from the
past they keep on dragging her down and
for her to move on and be a success she
has to drop her excess baggage and move
on what the [ __ ] was on in that bathroom
[Music]
after gordon left in the days that
followed scott took the next few weeks
to train a newly motivated luis and
arturo that's for the clams and muscles
yeah okay keep it here yeah that's fine
no problem welcome to the new lido and
with lisa's newfound kitchen expertise
from now on 100 just come straight to me
i can listen and make changes manhattan
beach's newest wine bar has seen a boost
in revenue i learned so much from gordon
ramsay the whole experience has been
amazing like it's
it's life-changing really this man has
given us everything
all the tools in the world like a dream
come true
now let's do it i really feel like i do
own the role of being the restaurant
owner now
you